hello
um hi i
am feeling weird giving a virtual talk
i guess i guess everybody's doing that
these days though
my name is ryan i'm going to
talk to you about this project dino
that i've been working on for the last
two years now or so
um we have just released version 1.0
about a month ago and
yeah i just thought i'd give you guys a
bit of an overview about it
uh and some demos and
uh if i understand the program correctly
hopefully
you can ask me some questions at the end
of it
so first off just a just a bit of an
overview um
so c plus plus and rust
and go are really interesting
developments
in in computer infrastructure they're
they're allowing us to uh
more easily
make machine code programs
and it's getting better all of the time
but
the fact remains that most software is
uh
not cpu bound and it seems that most
software is
is done in dynamic languages like python
and ruby and javascript
these dynamic languages aka scripts
are easy and succinct and
they often are the most minimal way to
describe certain algorithms
and amongst these these uh dynamic
languages
javascript is is arguably the fastest
and has the largest community of
programmers
because it's the language of the web
browser
um so
with that in mind uh back in in 2009
i started the node project to bring
javascript to to the server
um or out of the web browser that is
and this turned out to be a really
successful project
it's essentially turned into the phps of
the 2010s
and has ubiquitous
cloud support and is
used by uh essentially all
front-end frameworks
and yeah i mean in
in some way or another essentially every
website is using
node
but since 2009 the javascript
ecosystem has has improved uh
very rapidly and has
new features and systems that
were not around back then so for example
the
array buffer is a system to allow
uh accessing raw binary data in
javascript
that was not there when when we
originally designed the
the tcp system in in node
um async await of course is is
uh amazingly useful when you're dealing
with asynchronous systems
and most importantly the the es modules
has
has uh provided a way to
uh provided a module system a standard
module system in
in javascript um
and so dino uh
is is built uh
trying to take take advantage of of
these uh
new developments um so
in in many ways it's it's very similar
to node
uh you know it's it's a program for
executing javascript outside of the web
browser
and it's built on top of uh the v8
javascript vm
inside of chrome and it's open source
and
mit licensed uh but instead of c
plus it's written in rust and yeah kind
of the
the a lot
a lot of the utilities that it provides
are are quite different
so it has built-in dev tools for testing
and linting and formatting and dock
generation uh and it's been designed so
that it can be embedded in other
software
and it tries to use web apis
where it can with the idea that we want
to
we want this thing to be as broadly
usable as possible so
we really want to uh to
kind of uh appeal to
to developers uh
you know i i think the the web browser
is kind of the largest developer base
and by using those apis we we can appeal
to
the largest segment of the developer
population
um so dino is a bit different
in that uh you know it's it's making use
of
of these es modules um and it has this
this weird property where you can
actually put a raw http url into
as give give give a raw http url as
as the module specifier in import
statements
uh this is actually something that's
that's possible in
uh web browsers these days so it's it's
a
web compatible system
and what this allows you to do is is
basically import
code directly from the internet and
yeah this this has some uh some
interesting properties
um so you know when you talk about
importing code directly from the
internet
uh you quickly run into
into kind of some security questions
right
how do you know that you know you're
just pulling from from a random
url i mean what what sort of trust can
you have from that
um well i mean you know
if you're if you're pulling from a
random npm package what sort of trust
can you have
from it either right not not much uh but
you know this this kind of makes the the
fact that you're pulling random
code from the internet a bit more
explicit
uh not that you're not doing that
already and
with uh you know ruby gems or npm
packages uh you're certainly still
pulling random code from the internet
but because this makes it more explicit
uh you know we
we think that
it's important to uh to make use of
of the fact that v8 is a secure sandbox
uh and so so dino by default uh also
retains this security sandbox uh of
v8s and so uh
well let me let me jump into some demos
and and you'll see what i mean
um so first of all oops i need to
copy and paste this so what i'm going to
do
first is uh show a gist program
just is this uh github
pasting server and essentially it's it's
a
a way to to paste code on the internet
and there's an
api where you can you can basically post
post a file and then
send people get it get a url and and
send it to people
and so we've got this program and
this program is a is a is a url
to a typescript file and if i
enter it in my browser we've got this
website where it
displays the code and
the interesting thing here is is that
you know when you display it on
get it through the web browser you get
this this uh this website but
if you curl it uh you actually get the
raw
raw text um and the the way that we're
doing this is
is through uh the accept header
right so so web browsers can send an
accept header with with each request
that says oh i want
uh html um and based on that we're
we're able to either serve up the raw
content the the raw text file or not
anyway um what we're going to do
is dino has the ability to to download
this program
directly and uh run it
and so what what the way that this
program works
uh if i just run it uh i'm going to get
some permission error it says uncaught
permission denied
access to environment variables run
again with the allow
m flag so just in order to
to paste a gist uh and if you look
through the code you'll you'll see that
uh
that it's trying to get this
environmental
variable just token so that it knows how
to
which user to to post as on on just
um so you know we don't just allow
anybody to
have access to environmental variables
we have to give it
the allow m flag and
you know it's it's going to also need to
have allow
net because it's going to be accessing
some server but let yeah let's let's
just see that happen um so
right when we when we run it uh it's
it's
you know it's fetched my my secret
uh just token environmental variable
and now what we need to it's it's giving
me this usage
uh message because i haven't actually
given it a file to
uh to upload and so what i'm going to do
is try to
upload this this readme file that's in
my current directory
uh to the gist server and when i run
this i should get one more error which
is that
oh it doesn't have uh read access to the
file system
actually two more errors so we're going
to have to give it
dash allow read and uh just
skipping ahead we have to give it allow
net as well because it's going to
to access gist.github.com
um and when i run this it says oh
success
it's it's uh taken this file
and given me some url which if i go to
it
uh hopefully will contain this this dino
readme file
right so this is kind of
i i think the interesting thing about
this is is that
i didn't need to install anything right
this is a command line utility
um that you know previously you might
have
npm installed desk g to
to kind of get this this program but
here i'm i'm
running it without without installing
anything
now we do have kind of an install
version and the way this works
is that if i
uh i think if i so
i'm taking out the the readme because uh
okay so what i'm going to do is instead
of say demo run i'm going to say deno
install and what this is going to do
is it's basically going to create a
little shell
script oh it's it's erroring out because
i've already got it installed i'm going
to have to do
dash dash force to overwrite my previous
installation of of dino gist so it's
created this little shell
script and if i cut this shell script i
mean essentially it's just copy and
pasted this
this command line into this shell script
right
um and so so now now i can do things
like
uh just read me and uh
it will work like that so we have this
very simple way to
essentially create bookmarks to to
command line scripts
um right so so this is kind of what i
mean by
by a web browser for for command line
utilities or
even programs in general this
next example is is a whole website
actually
so when i run this i think this is
running a whole
react website so you know obviously this
gist program is
is pretty small but the claim here is
that we can do
kind of arbitrary complexity here and so
what i'm going to do is dino run allow
net allow read
and uh let's let's just take a look at
what this
what this uh program is um
you know it has some some relative
includes it's
it's including a or importing a tsx file
um starting some sort of server
um etc uh and it's i guess it's going to
be listening on
on port 3000. when i run this
uh hopefully it will work see listening
on port 3000
seems to have done it uh and
let's go there it says hello denno land
dino land and has kind of this example
react server you might have noticed that
this started up
really fast and there wasn't any
downloading or
anything happening that's because this
this file here is
is cached to my local my local machine
and you can find out more about the
cache
information if you type dino info oops
that was a lot of output so when i type
dino info
with with kind of the the entry point
script
um i i can find out that uh it has kind
of
a locally cached version in in this
directory
and this is a typescript program and so
it's it's been automatically compiled to
javascript and it exists in
in this location here and here's a
source map file
and then it even gives us a dependency
tree
all with all with valid urls and so so
this entry point depends on
mod tsx which in turn depends on
dep dot tes which in turn depends on
react from jspm and
so on right there's there's a lot of
dependencies in here
um so yeah just
just kind of as an example of of a more
complicated program
so where's my slides right so
even something more complicated here um
is this program which is also given as
a url and and i might as well
show you the source code first um
so this is also displaying a little
website but it's using this
this web view um and as you'll see it's
it's kind of a little
mini gui application and
it's going to create two windows a
really really simple thing
with uh but two native windows right
and the way that it does this is with
uh with dino's plugin interface which is
still unstable but essentially allows
you to plug into
essentially allows you to load a dll of
of uh that kind of can contain arbitrary
native code um
and yeah so that that's why we need this
unstable
and just fyi this dash capital a just
means
opt out of all of this security sandbox
nonsense
let's just let's just run it let's let's
let's be crazy
by the way if if you're loading a dll a
plug-in as we call them
uh you know kind of all your security
bets are off because we
uh we don't have uh you know if
if you're going into some some random
rust code
we we can't control what what you're
doing at that point
so you know the uh
oh okay so anyway i'm going to run this
and
as you see it's it's created these these
two windows here
um yeah so anyway i'll you know i'll
i'll leave this for you to play around
with but just just kind of
uh a sampling of of what dino can do
um and yeah i mentioned earlier that we
have a bunch of tooling so
let me do dino help and you'll see that
we've got all these sub commands
so we have like bundling and dock
and format and install and lint
so you know let me let me just give you
an example here
of let's say that gist file
or let's let's take this this entry
point dot ts
hopefully this works i haven't tried
this yet but let's let's just try to
bundle
bundle this guy right so what it's going
to do is it's going to
to create a single javascript file with
with all of the dependencies
bundled up in in here really crossing my
fingers now that this actually works
um maybe seem it it outputs it to
standard out
so yeah seems seems to have worked um
i'd rather show you these other tools uh
since
bundling exists uh let me let me show
you format
so so dino format is is essentially our
version of prettier but
implemented in rust and so much faster
and what i'm going to do is just format
some files i've got this directory here
i'm actually in the dino directory
and this is some code that's kind of
built into dino
we in in dino itself in our internal
stuff we actually don't use this dino
format yet we use uh prettier
uh still although hopefully we'll be
changing this
this soon uh but uh i'm just going to
use this as an example of
formatting a bunch of code right and
giving you a sense of of how long it
runs this is this is
uh yeah runs like that i guess
not not dissimilar to not dissimilar to
prettier and if i do a get diff uh
it's not exactly the same as prettier
but
it's pretty close um seems seems like
uh dino format likes trailing commas
right
uh whereas whereas prettier our prettier
current prettier situation does not so
um let me reset that
uh dino dock
is too fast too fast
uh dino dock uh okay so first of all
here's here's
uh some some server some some code
this is our http server so you can you
can throw this in the web browser and
and see the code here
uh what we have is uh we're able to
parse the ast and and kind of display
documentation
and so if you type dino doc and give a
url or
a relative path to some local source
code
we will print out a bunch of uh
documentation for this so we we can
parse out the the js doc comments
and the typescript types and and kind of
display them
and uh you know you can kind of narrow
in on some of this stuff so maybe if you
want to
learn more about server request you you
give that as another argument and you
can
you can kind of see see some more of it
and
of course we have json output so if you
want to have
kind of do a structured uh display of
this
and i i think this doesn't work with the
second argument so i think i need to do
that
right so if i if i give this json
argument here
then we get the same output that
was displayed previously but but in kind
of a computer readable form
and what's cool about this is that we've
actually
taken this and built a website around it
and so in the
dino website here if
you go to one of these these source code
links and click view documentation
will actually render out that json into
into a file into a documentation that
that you can view online
so yeah i mean essentially any any url
yeah and by the way if you go to uh dino
doc
and you can put in any any random url
here
right uh including things that are not
on dinoland
and it should be able to generate
documentation
for for that for that url
so one more thing dinolint this has just
now come out and this is essentially our
version
of our version of
of eslint it's unstable still so you
have to provide that unstable flag but
if i give it a directory of
source code which i'm going to give this
cli test unit this is a bunch of source
code
that has not been linted yet
you will see that it runs very fast
our our dino lint program you know is
not
feet does not yet have feature parity
with with uh
with eslint but we're making fast
progress with this
and uh we've clocked it in about
uh two orders of magnitude faster than
eslint
so do check this out and i should
mention that
dinolint is distributed as a standalone
rust crate
that is potentially usable inside
outside of dino itself and so so
potentially this could be used
uh for other
for node projects um so not not
necessarily dinosaur
specific all right so i'm
going quite slow here gotta speed it up
um
right so i should mention that you know
we we've
we've uh designed this this thing a bit
differently than node node is kind of
this monolithic
uh command line application dino is not
you know is a set of crates
and we've built it this way because
we've seen that there's
there's uh certain use cases where
you might want to execute some
javascript but not necessarily
spin up a whole node process right and
and
you know all of the things that come
with that install npm packages and
whatnot
so uh for example databases often use
javascript for map reduce functions or
serverless products like
cloudflare workers might want to execute
some javascript on every incoming
request
or say electron style gui applications
uh where where like vs code where where
you just need to
you need some programmability but you
don't necessarily want
uh the whole uh dino executable
uh so with that we've we've provided
this dino core crate which is a very
much
trimmed down api of of the dino
executable
and so i encourage you to look at that
dino core actually depends on an even
lower level
crate which is called rusty v8 this is
our wrapper around v8 that
is uh relatively safe
i'm not going to it's it's not 1.0 yet
so i'm not going to say that
it's it's a completely safe api but
it's a it's very close uh
to being a completely safe way to
interact with
an extremely complex vm
so please have a look if you're
interested in that
uh internal design of dino i'm just
going to speed through this really quick
uh we have we designed this quite
similarly to
to an operating system and so uh inside
of dino we
we have this idea of ops which are
equivalent to sys calls that's how you
reach out of the
of the vm and we have something called
like file
descriptors these are called resource
ids to not confuse things
and processes are essentially equivalent
to web workers in dino by the way we use
the
standard webworker api that you get in
the web browser
and the way that we organize all of this
is that
basically the only way to call in and
out of the vm is is
using un8 arrays array buffers
and you might think that that this sort
of serialization is
is quite slow but we've put a lot of
effort into this and
you know essentially there's these are
zero copy operations
uh there's uh we're essentially point
passing pointers back and forth from
from javascript to
to rust uh and yeah i i
won't go into any any more details on
that so
uh as i mentioned earlier dino is at 1.0
and the dino api is stable for the
foreseeable future we are fixing bugs
fixing bugs and
going to be fixing more bugs we will be
releasing
minor releases one point x releases on a
monthly cadence
uh 13th of every month and
yeah there's a lot of interesting future
work like op crates which allows
basically splits up the the cli into
into more useful
bits uh we are thinking heavily about
adding uh gpu support through through
web gpu or webgl apis to enable machine
learning applications
there's also this feature that people
are pretty interested in which is
dino compile which would take some
javascript and compile it to
a binary not really it would package up
the javascript and it would take a v8
and it would kind of
bundle this all up but at the end of the
day you would get
an executable so that i think those
things would be
quite interesting please reach out if
you
want to get involved so thank you very
much